also celebrating their longevity Soap
Opera Digest on stands now for 40 years
that's a lot of covers do you remember
your first cover I do I had the most
preposterous like early 90s hair is
covered with this Marisa Tomei and I
fact is versatile may was my girlfriend
on as the world turns Julianne Moore
replace my girl she was my second
girlfriend you want hookups I had my
share how many times are we married
we're married like twice I think we're
very twice engaged 18-ton crazy
storylines Jose when I went down in a
fiery plane crash I came back a couple
of years later with of course soap
amnesia well I was applying ghosts the
alien in my garage and the soap stare we
still got oh my god it's so good okay is
it just me or is my soaps they're pretty
much exactly the same as my blue steel I
mean what's going on without look right
here's the thing we've seen that a
thousand times haven't we do it's like
we're that go now who got it all right
all right I gotta work on that but I
gotta tell you I had a great time and I
hope to see some of those friends again
at the 43rd annual daytime emmys of
course that is set for Sunday May first